[Música]
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]
una mexicana bailando tango en buenos
aires quién lo diría
bueno sería lo lógico pensar después de
tantos años dedicada a la danza
empezando por gimnasia rítmica jazz
folclor bailes de salón danzón hasta que
un día no muy grato una lesión en la
columna freno todo este tiempo todo ese
proceso y todo ese aprendizaje
en el hospital escuchaba en el pasillo
que decían esta mujer tiene que ser muy
valiente o muy resiliente
lo de valiente me gustaba irme en porque
entendí en términos pero no de
resiliente era algo que no me quedaba
del todo claro no entendía pero bueno
luego de mucha terapia y rehabilitación
logré ponerme de pie y dejé mi vida en
mexico tomé la decisión de irme a buenos
aires
pese a todo pronóstico
me dediqué a estudiar tango de raíz
sucedió algo formidable porque todos
creemos que hablamos el mismo lenguaje
el mismo castellano y en buenos aires-
no es así hablan con su propio modismo y
al cambian los términos muchas palabras
no tenían coherencia y había que
aprender había que afrontar la realidad
hablamos distinto
pero también mi objetivo de llegar a
buenos aires era justamente aprender a
bailar tan
un nuevo afrontamiento no sé nada de
tango
bien me escribo en la facultad
y el primer maestro
brass
el equilibrio es autónomo
el equilibrio es autónoma el equilibrio
es autónomo y eso cómo se maneja bien a
lo que ellos se referían era a quitarnos
esta idea de que la bailarina de tango
la carga el varón el equilibrio es
autónomo se refiere a que yo debo de
tener autonomía en la postura que si el
hombre me suelta
yo no me muevo no me caigo
bien luego de mucha práctica y luego de
muchos ejercicios
logré tener el equilibrio autónomo wow
ya puedo bailar tango
no
llegaba a otro maestro y
usted ya tiene equilibrio verdad bien
pues ya siéntanse conforme
pero pues nomás estoy parada no sé
bailar
bien comienza el maestro y te empieza a
mostrar nuevas figuras nuevos
movimientos pasos posturas y las adopta
así
se empieza a fortalecer el autoestima
cada maestro iba depositando un granito
nuevo
en este proceso de aprendizaje
que había que hacer entonces
llegaba una maestra y me decía es que
tienes que hacerte responsable de la
nueva información y del dominio que
ahora posees
a qué se refiere yo soy bien responsable
vengo a clases y demás responsable de lo
que ahora sabes hacer todavía no llegaba
el momento de bailar con ningún
compañero
todavía estaba en el proceso de mis
primeros pasos nueva maestra
señores hay que tomar conciencia del
espacio que comparten
y decías ok yo tengo equilibrio autónomo
soy responsable ahora tengo que ser
consciente si yo soy bien consciente sé
que nada más me puedo desenvolver en
este espacio mi desplazamiento es solo
en esta área siempre y cuando el hombre
me lo proponga
y así cada clase proponía una nueva
forma de abordar el proceso de
aprendizaje
no niego que había momentos donde la
frustración se apoderaba y venía la
maestra de psico tango y te enseñaba a
transitar por esa frustración y a
tolerarla no todo estaba escrito
llega el momento en el que finalmente te
abrazas del primer compañero y hay que
transitar por la pista muy bien
comenzamos a bailar todo perfecto
y yo no somos los únicos en la pista
tocábamos con otras parejas que hacían
lo mismo
había que ejercitar nuestra sociabilidad
inteligente de qué manera si chocas
no peleas no discutes no frenas la danza
le hace saber a la pareja que te diste
cuenta de lo que sucedió pero sigues
transitando en el espacio donde te
corresponde
una vez culminado el proceso de
aprendizaje
regreso a mexico y comienzo a indagar
sobre el tema de esa palabra que venía
en mi mente
resiliencia
estudiando el doctor dagoberto flores lo
propone y lo plantea muy muy claramente
y él te dice que resiliencia es la
capacidad con la que nace todo ser
humano para salir triunfante luego de
transitar por la adversidad
ahí me venía claro yo había transitado
no por una adversidad por varias pero sí
ya lo de mi lesión había sido suficiente
era muy lógico entender que en todo este
proceso de aprendizaje de tango cada
maestro sin saberlo venía fortaleciendo
un pilar de mi propia resiliencia
así ustedes y todos en cada área nos
habremos de encontrar en situaciones
distintas no importa que me dedico pero
si me doy cuenta que estoy afrontando me
doy cuenta que estoy siendo autónomo
para desarrollar cierta actividad que
han mejorado mi autoestima mi conciencia
mi tolerancia a la frustración mi
responsabilidad
y mi sociabilidad inteligente entonces
podremos tener la certeza de que todos
en nuestra propia área si venimos
ejercitando los pilares de nuestra
propia resiliencia
[Aplausos]
[Música]